please walk me through your CV or please
introduce yourself and what's important
here is to not get lost in the minor
stuff do not talk for three minutes
about an internship that you did at high
school or something like that really
focus on the things that matter focus on
the recent things that are really
important and this already is an
important skill in business as well and
especially as in consultant the
interviewer wants to trust you that if
you use it in front of a client and
you're having such a professional
conversation that you can't distinguish
the things that matter from the things
that do not matter